did you ever think you'd be in america
it was her dream before she got here i
think that was never my dream
what to call america yes why you that
was my dream
is everybody from ukraine what's going
to america
oh my juvia
like a lot of ukrainian women just try
and get a guy to get them to america
am i right i mean
i don't like that so much hearing
because it's about my
country it's kind of same stereotypes
like
many people think that americans are so
[Music]
stupid
jovi's parents tell them a little bit
about ukraine
and girls that in ukraine and girls is
so much stricken
want to get to america it's not true
so you said it wasn't your dream to come
to america so
after you all get married do you plan to
stay in america
honestly it is hard to see but
i am really not sure
for me it would be nice to live
somewhere like budapest because it's so
close to my mom
does that concern you quinn does that
concern me
yeah yes
she wants to go to another country and
move jovi to another country
so that's a problem for us also
in the future if they have kids i mean
this could be hard for us to
see our grandkids i am afraid that
once they get married that's she's
got that hold and she will take him away
from us
we may lose our son you know
[Music]
you